bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie de
michael aimait bonjour michael dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine il y à eut d'abord
l'apparition d'une nouveauté dans le
catalogue de l'humour le bon mot à la
mode corrézienne jacques chirac affirme
à plusieurs reprises et devant les
caméras qu'il votera françois hollande
en 2012
humour corrézien on vous dit les députés
examiner cette semaine le texte
instaurant la prime dividendes dans les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés une
prime qui réussit l'exploit de fâcher
les patrons comme les syndicats mais les
députés n'ont pas apporté de
modifications au texte
enfin les socialistes à l'assemblée
cette semaine relance deux grands débats
de société avec une proposition de loi
sur le mariage homosexuel et un rapport
sur la légalisation contrôlée du
cannabis
des débats qui on va le voir dépasse les
clivages droite gauche est notre invité
cette semaine jean christophe lagarde
bonjour toujours député maire de drancy
une ville de seine saint denis vous qui
administre depuis 2001 vice président de
l'assemblée nationale vous avez été un
très proche de françois bayrou à
l'époque de 2007 avant qu'il rejoigne un
petit peu près de ségolène royal au
deuxième tour et puis vous êtes partis
avec un bon nombre de vos camarades
partis pour le former le nouveau centre
que dont vous êtes aujourd'hui le numéro
2 vous êtes aussi très impliquée dans
l'alliance ce rapprochement des centres
à ce titre vous soutenez une candidature
centriste pour la présidentielle qui
devrait être incarné par jean louis
borloo borloo candidat une candidats qui
une candidature qui évidemment fâchent à
l'elysée avez vous toujours l'impression
aujourd'hui de faire partie d'une
majorité présidentielle mais une
majorité c'est nécessairement une
alliance jusqu'à présent il ya eu plus
un parti majoritaire absolue l'ump et
puis ceux qui s'y agréger sans avoir
leur mot à dire 100 ans pouvant parfois
donner leur opinion mais dont on ne
tenait jamais content est ce que nous
voulons bâtir c'est une alliance réel
avec deux alliés qui se parlent où il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue
y compris parce que nous avons nous
ambitionnons derrière jean-louis borloo
de diriger cette majorité après les
prochaines présidentielles mais avec une
alliance pas d'un côté les patrons et
ceux qui ont une question toujours dans
la majorité
écoutez quelle est l'autre option
s'allier avec les artistes s'allier avec
le parti socialiste et monsieur
mélenchon que monsieur gayant leurs
visages béraud mais ça c'est pas
l'indépendance l isolement pour
gouverner on peut pas gouverner seul
l'indépendance et le chou la liberté de
choisir ses alliances aujourd'hui
monsieur bayrou dit je ne suis pas prêt
à gouverner avec la droite et le centre
droit
je peux l'envisager avec la gauche c'est
son droit mais c'est pas l'indépendance
c'est du centre gauche dans c'est
toujours dedans mais avec son mot à dire
non c'est essayer de diriger et de
permettre aux français d'avoir le choix
il n'y a pas de raison pour que ce soit
dans cette majorité toujours la partie
la plus à droite qui gouverne les
français à chaque élection
présidentielle ils ont choisi l'endroit
choisir et nous souhaitons leur offrir
ce choix quoi de plus normal vous savez
si les français étaient privés de choix
c'est là où on risquerait l'accident
démocratique comme on en a déjà connu en
2002 c'est ce que jean louis borloo a
appelé être assis sur ses deux jambes
c'est bien ça jusqu'à présent que moi
j'observe que la majorité quand elle
fonctionne sur un pied elle clôt dit
qu'elle tombait elles chuté elle perd à
toutes les élections parce que il y a
deux sensibilités une sensibilité qui
est plus droitière plus libérale comment
dirais-je et prénationale et puis une
sensibilité plus humaniste sociale
européenne et même fédéraliste
européenne que nous incarnons quand
cette deuxième sensibilité et ignorer
les scores de la majorité diminuent au
point de devenir minoritaires
ce n'est pas notre ambition parce que je
pense pas que ce soit une bonne solution
de nous retrouver avec une alliance
entre le parti socialiste les verts et
monsieur mélenchon on a déjà connu on a
vu que ça fait plus reculer la france
que progresser les français ont fait
l'actualité de ce début de semaine
jacques chirac annonce ses intentions
pour les votes à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
et pour l'ancien président de la
république c'était de l'humour corrézien
certains évoquent une bourde d'autres
une attaque en règle contre nicolas
sarkozy en tout cas jacques chirac a mis
le feu aux poudres lors d'une visite
avec françois hollande sur ses terres
corréziennes il a livré sa préférence
pour le candidat socialiste céline
bittner
c'est une petite phrase qui ne fait pas
vraiment rire à droite depuis que
jacques chirac a apporté son soutien à
françois hollande pour 2012
les proches de l'ancien président de la
république font tout pour calmer le jeu
le mot d'ordre est le même minimisé les
propos de leur ancien mentor plus
plaisante avec des proches même si
politiquement ce ne sont pas des
compagnons de route mais des proches et
entre élus locaux on a l'habitude de
travailler ensemble de plaisanter alors
les déclarations de jacques chirac
simplement de l'humour corrézien
c'est ce qu'affirme l'ancien président
de la république a dû faire marche
arrière
la majorité aussi veut s'en convaincre
objectif ne pas trop commenter le
désamour de jacques chirac à l'encontre
de nicolas sarkozy il ne fait plus de
politique
il ne veut pas gêner son successeur il
ne formule aucune observation aucun
commentaire sur l'action du gouvernement
il a tourné la page
malaise à droite mais aussi à gauche le
soutien d'un homme de droite
embarrassant pour françois hollande
avant les primaires au parti socialiste
davis et amy
je lui ai sauté sur le mois de mai
change
à gauche d'autres y voit la
reconnaissance de l'échec de la majorité
c'est formidable qu'un ancien président
de la république n'est pas la langue de
bois ce qu'il écrit c'est ce qu'on
savait depuis longtemps savoir que ne
considère pas que monsieur sarkozy
souhaite un homme d'état je crois que
comme beaucoup de personnes de droite
jacques chirac ne s'est pas retrouvé
dans le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
et c'est ce que je retiens de de cette
déclaration
une blague qui a en tout cas fait parler
toute la classe police politique mais
qui n'a visiblement pas amusé l'elysée
où aucun commentaire n'a filtré alors
jean christophe lagarde cette petite
phrase de jacques chirac c'est un sale
coup pour nicolas sarkozy ou pour
françois hollande
je crois surtout déjà qu'on a beaucoup
trop commenter mais enfin bref on savait
parfaitement ce qu'il faisait je vous
rappelle que jacques chirac est en train
de publier un livre ça fait une très
bonne promo pour le livre et puis si en
plus ça permet d' agacer quelques amis
qui n'ont pas toujours été suffisamment
respectueux de son point de vue tant
mieux est-ce que ça a un impact
politique je le crois pas c'est pour ça
que je trouve qu'on a beaucoup trop
commenter parce qu'elle l'a fait
sciemment pour ça pour sa promo je pense
que la promotion et énerver ses amis ça
peut être un objet ou un dernier objet
mais ça on le voit à travers d'autres
attitudes qu'il a avec une jeune femme
blonde qui se trouvait juste derrière
pendant le reportage
jacques chirac c'est quelqu'un qui dans
sa vie publique a pendant 40-45 ans
étaient obligés de se contrôler chaque
minute on voit bien que depuis qu'il est
président il a envie de se lâcher un peu
dans ses mémoires jacques chirac parle
de nicolas sarkozy un homme nerveux
impétueux ne doutant de rien et surtout
pas de lui-même vous êtes d'accord avec
cette définition de nicolas sarkozy
alors d'abord ne doutant pas de rien en
fin de temps de rien et surtout pas lui
même oui mais je crois qu'aucun
président de la république de lui même
parce que c'est quand même pas une
fonction tout à fait banal employé faire
tout à leur dire qu' il fallait un
président normal à la france si le rôle
de président c'est normal il ya quand
même quelque chose qui m'échappe
ça n'a pas droite c'était impétueux qui
ne l'auraient pas remarqué mais il a
aussi été quand même capable de franchir
des lignes que personne ne
franchissaient notamment dans les
périodes de crise je crois que nicolas
sarkozy sa principale qualité c'est
quand y ait une crise toute son énergie
sert à dénouer la crise y compris au
niveau international après dans les
temps plus qu'à la même qui n'agit que
dans la crise
en tout cas le plus performant dans la
crise après dans les temps plus calme il
ya beaucoup à redire c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je pense qu'elle
nécessite et alternatives auxquelles
vous connaissez la dernière blague
corrézienne qui circulent c'est chaque
chirac qui dirait je vote pour nicolas
sarkozy
je pense que c'est de l'humour kolarov à
six versions hollande voilà allez vous
passer au mardi avec une proposition
socialiste
et si on ouvrait le mariage aux couples
du même sexe
les députés en ce mardi doivent donc se
pencher sur une proposition de loi
socialiste visant à instaurer le mariage
homosexuel
c'est la première fois que cette
importante question de société arrive
jusqu'à l'hémicycle sans surprise le
texte a été rejeté mais pas à
l'unanimité des voix de droite
une dizaine de députés de la majorité
dont vous jean christophe lagarde ont
voté pour d'autres se sont abstenus
julien le correct l'homme du jour c'est
lui le jeune député ump franck riester
à 37 ans il a décidé de s'engager pour
le mariage homo cet après midi dans
l'hémicycle il votera pour la
proposition de loi socialiste
moi je respecte encore une fois
l'opinion de ces et ceux qui pensent
différemment de moi mais quand on est
député sur des sujets de société
particulièrement il faut voter en son
âme et conscience est ce que je vais
faire
et puis je crois que ça transcende les
clivages politiques il ya des gens parti
socialiste qui sont contre donc on verra
comment les débats vont évoluer dans
l'hémicycle mais en tout cas en tant que
député je m'exprime en mon âme et
conscience et je voterai pour changement
de mentalité ou positionnement politique
les autres députés de la majorité qui
défendent la même position eux sont en
rupture de ban avec la majorité
présidentielle des prises de positions
très isolé car à l'ump une majorité des
députés n'est pas favorable à cette loi
je crois qu'elle n'ait pas demandé sauf
par une petite intelligentia qui le
demandent
avec beaucoup de bruit mais les ennemis
j'ai pu voir ce que j'ai pu entendre
écouter sont pas demandeurs on peut
faire l'égalité des droits et des
devoirs on peut imaginer effectivement
une progression du pacs mais je seek le
mariage a une valeur symbolique que nous
devons conserver entre un homme et une
femme pas favorable pour certains
d'autres sont encore farouchement
opposée au mariage gay brigitte barèges
s'est tristement illustré en déclarant
en commission et pourquoi pas le mariage
avec les animaux ou la polygamie
des propos aussitôt condamné par son
propre camp mais qui démonte quand même
qu'en politique la cause homosexuelle
encore du chemin à faire
non jean christophe lagarde me fait
partie de ces quelques députés de la
majorité qui ont voté pour le mariage
homosexuel pour quelles raisons d'abord
quand j'écoutais jean le bernard debré
je me disais est ce qu'une loi ça se
demande et moi on l'a fait parce qu'elle
est nécessaire et parce qu'elle est
équitable quand j'écoute et claude
goasguen à l'instant il disait grosso
modo on doit garder un symbole
tous les droits et devoirs et pas le
symbole j'ai même entendu d'autres
hommes politiques d'hier on doit pas
accorder le sacrement du mariage là
c'est tout le problème c'est que dans la
république à la mairie devant le maire
le mariage c'est pas un sacrement
c'est un contrat qui est établie entre
deux personnes et qui fait d'eux un
couple si on donne tous les droits du
contrat et qu'on refuse la cérémonie en
mairie
c'est purement de la discrimination et
une confusion mais c'est celui qui
commande la discrimination
je serais surpris pour pas dire choquée
que des religions accepte le mariage
homosexuel mais la république elle tient
pas compte d'une espèce de morale
religieuse tout à fait respectable que
je respecte que je peux partager mais la
république elle ne fait pas le tri et
donc si on donne tous les droits
c'est même la position de nicolas
sarkozy je me souviens pendant la
campagne présidentielle c'est la
position d'un certain nombre de nos
collègues de la majorité
si on donne tous les droits on va
jusqu'au symbole à la cérémonie parce
que sinon on discrimine est
objectivement je suis frappé que la
société française s'est pas seulement
dans ce cas là mais a beaucoup plus
évoluée que la classe politique ou que
les élus
dans cette affaire et ça me fait un peu
penser à ce qui s'était passé vous savez
avant 1980 quand une partie de la classe
politique en l'occurrence la droite qui
était au pouvoir se crisper sur les
radios libres
aujourd'hui ils auraient l'idée de
contester les radios libres et pourtant
il était là la société politique la
classe politique est en retard dans son
rôle c'est plutôt d'être en avance et de
montrer le chemin et on voit bien que
dans ce cas là elle est en retard c'est
regrettable
au nom de quoi donner tous les droits et
refuser la cérémonie au nom de quoi au
nom d'une morale religieuse elle est
tout à fait respectable ça veut dire que
vous ne passerez pas de la mairie à
l'église ou à la synagogue ou à la
mosquée et vous avez le droit de passer
à la mairie leaké tendance à l'heure
alors il ya une ministre qui est
parfaitement d'accord avec vous c'est
roselyne bachelot il est peut-être
entendu mais il arrive t elle estime que
c'est une réforme inévitable et qui se
fera de toute façon dit elle alors dans
la foulée des députés de la droite
populaire ont jugé ces propos
inadmissibles ils ont réclamé sa
démission cette semaine on écoute l'un
d'entre eux
madame bachelot a effectivement le droit
de penser en son for intérieur que il
faut accepter ce mariage la lan miniter
d'ailleurs pour le pacs quand elle était
parlementaire
mais quand on est membre d'un
gouvernement que la majorité
parlementaire vient de voter de rejeter
ce texte on n'a pas le droit d'agir
ainsi
c'est une question de responsabilité et
de cohérence alors là ils contestent la
méthode c'est à dire que roselyne
bachelot n'aurait pas à s'opposer en
tant que ministre à la représentation du
peuple qui a voté non pas le front parle
de la méthode e et monsieur myard a deux
fois tort le gouvernement dans cette
affaire
il n'était pas en cause c'est une
proposition de loi d'un parlementaire et
nous nous prononçons sur des
propositions de lois et de la même façon
un ministre a parfaitement le droit
d'avoir il n'y a pas de rupture de la
solidarité gouvernementale sur la forme
il a tort mais sur le fond il a aussi
vous me demandiez tout à l'heure
pourquoi il fallait une alternative à
l'élection présidentielle pourquoi nous
souhaitons rassembler les centres
pourquoi nous souhaitons avoir un
candidat parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
que ce soit toujours cette droite là la
plus à droite dite populaire est en
réalité la plus adroite et la plus
réactionnaire qui soit la seule à donner
le ton au point que quand quelqu'un
donne un avis différent d'eux ils en
demandent la démission et on l'entend
souvent saoul dans cette droite
populaire à la flambée du meilleur et
malheureusement le centre de gravité si
j'ose dire de la majorité s'est déplacée
vers eux
nous allons rééquilibrer proposer aux
français de leur équilibre parce que
pour l'instant il ya très clairement un
déficit de parole de la droite centriste
comme vous par rapport à cette droite
populaire qui a envahi le terrain des
radars la double nationalité
c'est normal si vous pouvez me lasser si
vous me le permettez vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure la campagne de 2007 avec
françois bayrou
depuis 2007 le centre est éclatée était
éclatée dispersé éparpillés donc
inaudible donc ne pesant pas assez sur
les débats et si nous avons voulu qu'on
peut créer l'alliance républicaine
écologique et sociale
en rassemblant les mouvements centristes
éparpillés si nous souhaitons proposer
une alternative à la présidentielle
c'est parce qu'il ya 20 à 25 % de
français qui partagent notre sensibilité
mais qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans ce
genre de propos d' attitude qui fait que
quand on n'est pas d'accord faut partir
ou faut exclure
c'est pas comme ça que fonctionne notre
gamme vous dit à l'instant donc le
nouveau centre n'a pas été assez
entendus pendant ces quelques années
bien sûr si si si ça avait été le cas et
que comme je le disais tout à l'heure
les alliés avec des amis pour les alliés
avaient effectivement été des alliés non
c'est pas prendre alors on s'est pas
donné le poids c'est pas qu'on n'a pas
voulu il ya six mois vous nous disiez
que les centristes étaient incapables de
se réunir aujourd'hui se sont réunies on
n'y est pas arrivé avant on y arrive à
temps pour proposer un choix aux
français
même là la stratégie de nicolas sarkozy
qui consiste donc à écouter sa droite
populaire à aller ratisser du côté des
terres du fn c'est une mauvaise
stratégie avant 2012 à votre avis c'est
une tendance toujours avant les
élections qu'un président de la
république de droite issu de la droite
est une dette de droite ça ne me pose
pas de problème c'est son rôle je serai
plus surpris de voir nicolas sarkozy
jouer au centre gauche
donc c'est pas vraiment ça mais que
vertus que que dans toutes les grandes
démocraties dans le monde
ce n'est pas un parti qu'il dirige parce
que quand c'est un particules qui dirige
il est forcément six états partis de
droite tiré vers sa droite
et si c'est un parti de gauche tirait
vers sa gauche ce sont des coalitions et
la coalition ça donne la chance dans des
sociétés complexes de l'equilibre du
rassemblement pour parvenir à surmonter
les défis qui sont les nôtres
regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer en grèce le fait de ne pas avoir
un pôle d'équilibré suffisant et bien ne
sont pas capables de trouver une sortie
politique et une sortie financière et
économique à leur système leur situation
situation dans laquelle ils sont tous
jean christophe lagarde mardi toujours
le sénat s'installe sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui vise à inscrire le
retour à l'équilibré des comptes publics
dans la constitution un vote difficile à
obtenir pour le gouvernement le ministre
du budget est venu en personne
convaincre les sénateurs de la majorité
qui ont voté mais en apportant quelques
amendements marie brémond opération
difficile ce matin pour françois baron
au sénat le ministre du budget a tenté
de convaincre lors des réunions de
groupes ump et centristes les sénateurs
de la nécessité d'une règle d'or
budgétaire ce texte qui vise à inscrire
le retour à l'équilibré des comptes
publics dans la constitution mais
visiblement au sein de la majorité les
réticences au projet de loi persiste et
je crois que c'est important de faire en
sorte que tout le monde soit vertueux y
compris le gouvernement je crois que
c'est lassant c'est le sens de la règle
d'or
simplement ça doit pas se faire au
détriment de l'initiative parlementaire
les initiatives parlementaires seraient
sérieusement restreinte c'est ce que
pensent les sénateurs du texte adopté en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
il sera plus possible dans une
proposition de loi d'avoir un dispositif
qui a des conséquences budgétaires y
compris pour créer des recettes
donc on sera des saisies d'une grande
partie de notre rôle de parlementaire et
donc ça va totalement à l'encontre de la
revalorisation demandée en 2008
quant à la gauche elle y voit notamment
une manoeuvre politique
pourquoi simplement faire la
démonstration que la gauche d'un côté
serait laxiste et que de l'autre côté la
majorité de droite dans ce pays elle
serait au contraire guidés par leur
vigueur s'est passé des choses car si
tout le monde s'accorde sur la nécessité
de réduire le déficit abyssal de la
france
les méthodes pour y parvenir divergent
nicolas sarkozy voulait avant le début
des vacances faire adopter en congrès
cette règle d'or budgétaire pour
notamment assurer de sa bonne volonté à
l'union européenne mais le président de
la république aujourd'hui voit se
scénario idéal quelque peu s'éloigner
alors jean christophe lagarde comment
vous voyez ces centres et ces sénateurs
centristes qui participent à ces
amendements qui obtiennent gain de cause
chinoises ont beaucoup plus de poids que
l'assemblée nationale mais parce que
l'assemblée nationale à chaque fois
qu'on discute d'un texte si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec le texte c'est vrai
pour les députés ump ou pour les
et centristes on vous dit vous
remettez en cause la totalité des
gouvernements ce qui est infantilisant
et stupide moi je suis pour qu'on retire
la responsabilité du gouvernement devant
l'assemblée nationale pour nous redonner
le pouvoir de discuter texte par texte
plutôt que nous imposer une espèce de
chantage politique avec cette fameuse
arme atomique qu'on connaît qui est le
49-3 mais si vous le permettez je trouve
qu'on n'a pas assez souligné que c'est
une belle victoire des centristes ça
nous avons dit dès 2007 au moins deux
choses importantes
nous voulions la suppression du bouclier
fiscal nous venons de l'obtenir
malheureusement on n'a pas été écouté
pendant trois ans quatre ans et le
problème de l'équipe de la majorité dont
je vous parle tout cas dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et nous avions
dit nous voulons dehors de la réforme
constitutionnelle j'étais le
porte-parole de mon groupe à l'assemblée
nationale nous voulons introduire une
règle d'or pour que l'irresponsabilité
budgétaire des gouvernements qui se sont
succédé depuis 30 ans et qui ont creusé
un une dette publique de 1500 à 2500
milliards d'euros nous l'avions abordés
pendant la campagne présidentielle et
législatives ont convenu qu'on y mette
fin que comme en allemagne il ya une
règle qui oblige les politiques est
responsable et à dire aux français quand
on n'a pas d'argent on dépense pas ou
alors on a besoin de plus de recettes et
de plus d'impôts attendez c'est d'abord
on nous disait c'est irresponsable c'est
impossible ce n'est pas nécessaire
aujourd'hui au moins la majorité est
convaincu qu'il faut le faire et moi je
souhaite qu'on aille au sénat
je souhaite qu'on aille au congrès
regardant un congrès du parlement je
souhaite qu'on gagne parce qu'on verra
qui fait des phrases et qui est prêt à
appuyer par son pote si ça ne passe pas
ça ne passe pas mais les français
pourront juger sur itélé 3/5 l école s à
l'échec
pardon moi je pense qu'il doit le
prendre pour la france parce qu'il est
président de la république
et s'il ya échec comme vous dites il ya
des députés qui se représente au mois de
juin prochain il faudra qu'ils
expliquent aux gens pourquoi ils veulent
continuer la gabegie pourquoi ils
veulent faire perdre à la france sa
fameuse note de triple a qui nous permet
de payer 15 milliards d'intérêts
d'intérêts en moins chaque année alors
que si on perd la note la note triple à
ces 15 milliards le tiers du quasiment
le tiers du budget de l'éducation
nationale qui s'empare qui partent en
fumée dans les banques
alors soit on devient responsable soit
on fait disparaître le quart du budget
de l'éducation nationale
je demande au président de la république
effectivement de convoquer le congrès et
que chacun des parlementaires sénateurs
qui se présente pour
une partie d'entre vous qui se
représentant dans quelques années et
député d'assumer leurs responsabilités
pour la france pas pour eux pas pour
l'heure pas dans l'objectif des
élections présidentielles christophe
lagarde
la lutte contre les déficits la haine
contre la dette c'est là notre cheval de
bataille et si on parlait de la grèce de
ces manifestations qui ont eu lieu cette
semaine
faut-il aider à tout prix la grèce à
tout prix non à tout prix blonde et
encore oui en quoi comme un petit peu
encore joli mais il faut bien que les
français comprennent ce qui se passe les
responsabilités budgétaires de nombreux
gouvernements et d'engrais ça a été pire
que tout en europe fait qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont les allemands qui payent des
dépenses que les autres ont fait nous
compris ce sont les allemands qui font
les efforts et qu'ils fixent des règles
en disant on veut pas continuer à payer
si vous n'êtes pas sérieux dans votre
gestion
tout le monde sait qu'en grèce les
droits sociaux étaient tellement
exorbitant
regardez la progression de large de la
retraite de mémoire ils ont été obligés
de rallongée de huit ans il était à 57
ans quand nous on était à 60
comment dirais-je les impôts en grèce ne
sont pas prélevés
il ya très peu d'impôts prélevés et les
riches ont effectivement l'a bien vu
quand il est entré dans l'europe ça
c'était pas une découverte on le savait
déjà je viens et les riches sont
exonérés et donc à partir du moment où
nous avons une monnaie unique
et heureusement que nous l'avons sinon
la france aujourd'hui serait à la
ramasse autant que les autres à partir
du moment où nous avons une monnaie
unique
il faut accepter d'avoir des politiques
économiques qui soient uniques regrouper
ou fédérer et à que je sais votre
géniaux je suis et nous sommes nous
centristes pour qu'on continue à faire
avancer l'europe
de sorte que les décisions elles soient
prises notamment de politique économique
de politique fiscale au niveau européen
permettant d'avoir une cohérence une
cohésion et donc une force si nous ne
faisons pas non seulement on connaît des
problèmes internes et des crises
sociales dramatiques effectivement comme
on en connaît andres et comme horizon
connaître dans d'autres pays mais
surtout notre compétitivité se trouve
tellement altéré que ce qui fixe les
règles du jeu ce sont les chinois les
américains essaient jamais à notre
profit c'est toujours à notre détriment
est ce qu'il ya un risque pour que la
grèce sorte de la zone euro oui je pense
qu'il ya un risque aujourd'hui que
dire le contraire ne ne serait pas dire
la vérité je souhaite que ce ne soit pas
le cas et je pense à d'autres pays comme
les jeux les jeux pan non je pense que
pour l'instant la grèce est réellement
la seule qui est dans cette situation là
parce que son équilibre politique sa
situation politique ne permet pas
d'avoir comment dirais-je un plan de
redressement qui soit
budgétairement économiquement
responsable et socialement acceptable
les gens qui sont les indignés sont
effectivement les plus touchés et je
comprends leur situation
la question du pouvoir grec c est ce
qu'ils vont faire payer les riches là
bas parce que là bas le taux
d'imposition entre guillemets des plus
riches de la société grecque le taux
d'évasion fiscale de fraude fiscale est
colossal abyssal et suffirait largement
à soulager les difficultés des gens qui
sont ici
mais si on permettait juste une dernière
phrase on a beaucoup critiqué la
politique économique de la majorité je
pense que sa politique sociale est très
discutable mais la politique économique
de la majorité nous a permis quand même
une chose
là où dans des pays comme l'espagne
comme la grèce on a baissé les salaires
baisser les salaires y compris des
fonctionnaires où on a augmenté les
impôts en france on n'a pas baissé les
salaires on n'a pas augmenté les impôts
et on a eu moins de perte de croissance
est moins d'augmentation de chômage
d'ailleurs à travailler dans une période
de crise la france a plutôt limité la
casse
et quand on regarde par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé à côté quand vous voyez
aujourd'hui qu'en grèce au portugal des
milliers de jeunes disent qu'ils
voudraient quitter leur pays émigré ce
qui ne se produit plus depuis 30 à 35
ans on prend conscience de la puissance
de la crise et du fait que le modèle
social français finalement a permis de
prouver que sa carrière a permis de
contenir des choses il est largement
perfectible parce qu'on a un vrai
problème d'équité des efforts les
efforts ne sont pas équitablement
répartis dans d'autres pays
et ça passe notamment par une voix pas
les normes anti flag à revenir donc à
votre famille centriste puisque mardi
toujours c'était l'assemblée de la
confédération des centres qui regroupe
le parti radical le nouveau centre la
gauche moderne et la convention
démocrate en vue de 2012
en attendant cette échéance l'autre
question était de savoir si de nouveaux
centristes étaient prêts à entrer au
gouvernement en cas de remaniement fin
juin réponse de jean louis borloo nous
on nous le sentiment que cette vision
sociale cette vision qui tente à
construire ensemble à ne pas opposer les
uns aux autres voilà cette dimension là
elle n'est pas assez présente
on veut la défendre on l'a d'efforts
faisant de cette alliance
et si certains d'entre nous peuvent la
défendre même au gouvernement au
parlement en en est grave et six touches
gouvernement pouvait être centriste
je viens je serais ravi ce serait mieux
dit de vous falloir ce remaniement
excuse moi je suis présentée parce que
justement je crois profondément qu'il
faut une coalition quel que soit le
gouvernement que les français choisiront
et qu'un parti seul se trompe tout seul
alors que des partis qui sont obligés de
se parler qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue sont des partis qui sont obligé
d'équilibrer leur politique et donc de
mieux prendre en compte les intérêts et
les aspirations alors il y aura un
remaniement c'est christine lagarde
prend la tête du fmi
quand on regarde un peu l'heure vous
avez été contacté vous même pour entrer
au gouvernement
je n'ai pas été contacté j'ai bien
l'intention de terminer mon mandat de
député
d'accord mais si vous aviez à choisir
sur vous disais le choix est fait je ne
vous le dira oui et un poste de ministre
du budget par exemple c'est quelque
chose qui pour shu et déjà fait je viens
de vous le dire je terminerai mon mandat
de député
écoutez si par extraordinaire il prenait
la fantaisie de nicolas sarkozy de
nommer à matignon je réfléchirai séparés
comme ça ne paraît pas tout à fait
probable ministres vont réfléchir y est
on notre choix est claire et définitive
alors quand on entend que jean louis
borloo qui dit ça serait formidable s'il
y avait plein de centristes au
gouvernement on a fini en un peu de mal
à suivre la logique parce que ça fait
sept mois qui tente de prendre son
indépendance et finalement être
gouvernement ça lui va donc c'est quoi
ces indépendances elle les gens sont
on a du mal à suivre la stratégie c'est
curieux que vous ayez intégré depuis dix
ans qui est une section une situation
assez exceptionnelle ou un parti à la
majorité absolue c'est la première fois
que ça se produit
et parce que ça existe depuis dix ans
vous avez intégré que c'est la vie
politique normale ce n'est pas la vie
politique normale et être dans un
gouvernement
du temps où les socialistes les verts et
les communistes dirigent ensemble
ou quand le rpr et l'udf diriger
ensemble ça veut pas dire être d'accord
sur tout l'uniformité de la majorité
donc c'est ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai à droite ou au centre et
c'est vrai à gauche pas du tout ça veut
dire que dans un gouvernement il ya des
débats jean louis borloo il n'a pas
toujours été d'accord avec ce qui se
passait au sein du gouvernement hervé
morin n'a pas toujours été d'accord à
l'extérieur vous pouvez pas le dire je
vais essayer d'emporter le morceau à
yann non plus mais ils n'y sont plus que
vous allez vous en portez vous essayer
d'emporter le morceau à l'intérieur du
gouvernement et si vous ne parvenez pas
vous avez un choix si vraiment vous
n'êtes plus d'accord vous partez je vous
ferai remarquer en l'occurrence que les
gens que je viens de citer effectivement
son parti c'est pas pour se taire c'est
pas pour disparaître
se taire c'est est dans le gouvernement
à l'extérieur il ya possibilité de
rétablir à la fois un équilibre est de
proposer un choix aux français c'est
bien ce que nous sommes en train de
faire au nom de quoi ce serait
illégitime
je répète ce que je disais tout à
l'heure pour quoi il n'y aurait que la
droite populaire qui aurait droit de
parler dans ce pays alors soit vous êtes
avec la droite populaire soit vous êtes
avec le parti socialiste et monsieur
mélenchon donc pas prêt je ne suis pas
d'accord je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cette vision là et ce n'est pas parce
que depuis dix ans nous avons une
majorité unique sur un parti unique à
l'assemblée que c'est un bon système
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est un système
qui a lassé les français et qu'ils
aspirent à ce qu'ils aient une coalition
qui dirige notre pays et qui permettent
en l'occurrence de transformer la france
qui a besoin de s'adapter à de
nombreuses choses mais de faire en sorte
que les efforts que nous avons affaire
soit équitablement partagé ce n'est pas
le sentiment qu'ils sont lus et ils
n'ont pas tout à fait
on passe au mercredi l'as anglais au
vote une prime entre défense du pouvoir
d'achat
le texte prévoit le versement d'une
prime obligatoire pour les salariés
d'entreprises de plus de 50 personnes
une prime qui pourrait atteindre jusqu'à
1200 euros elle pourrait concerner
environ quatre millions de salariés
la gauche dénonce un miroir aux
alouettes dans l'hémicycle les débats
ont été animés écouter cet extrait entre
le député ps jean mallot et la réponse
du ministre xavier bertrand
au bout du compte votre loterie puisque
c'est ça au fond ne concernera qu'un
homme extrêmement restreint de salariés
qui toucheront de façon exceptionnelle
dans les entreprises déjà florissante
avec une niche sociale qui est quand
même paradoxal une prime tout à fait
réduit tant dans son montant
on voit bien qu'elle est la tactique de
l'opposition n'ayant rien à dire sur le
fond étant très gêné sur le fond vous
tentez de parasiter ce texte
ainsi pour essayer de créer la confusion
parce que regarder les scènes les
rémunérations de quelques patrons
augmente voulait agir
les dividendes augmentent vous ne voulez
pas agir ce qui apporte aujourd'hui en
plus pour les salariés c'est nous que ça
vous gêne je le comprends il est pas
trop tard pour que vous nous rejoignez
sur ce texte
jean christophe lagarde et patrons ont
opposé des syndicats sceptiques
bref cette prime passe mal les syndicats
c'est le rôle de sceptiques et demandé
de les battre us les patrons c'est une
constante du patronat français s'est pas
de restes du patronat du monde sait qu'à
chaque fois qu'il s'agit en l'occurrence
de partager les gains de l'entreprise
il considère qu'il y en a pas pour les
salariés et c'est pas une nouveauté dans
les années 60 de gaulle s'est déjà
heurté à ça la participation se vous dit
rien et quand on il ya un caractère
fossé au débat actuel
c'est pas une question de pouvoir
d'achat qui est en cause là le pouvoir
d'achat c'est dans la négociation
salariale et c'est effectivement
compliqué parce qu'il faut pas non plus
dégradé les compétiteurs la
compétitivité des entreprises et je
pense que le pouvoir d'achat on ferait
mieux de regarder du côté du logement et
du prix du logement qui a été multiplié
par deux et demi qu'il a vraiment
beaucoup plus attaquées de le pouvoir
d'achat en revanche en revanche c'est
une excellente je disais qu'il fallait
des alternatives une alternative et je
le maintiens mais c'est une excellente
initiative de nicolas sarkozy ça fâche
les patrons tant pis parce que on a
besoin d'un grand bouleversement en
france sur le partage de la richesse
entre le capital et le travail que le
capital s'investissent dans une
entreprise et permettent la création de
richesses et qu'il en soit rémunéré
c'est normal il n'y a pas d'autre
système
puisse fonctionner qu'en revanche
pendant que l'entreprise gagne de
l'argent
le salarié n'en profite pas ça ça n'est
pas normal alors elle n'est peut-être
pas parfaite la réforme elle doit
profiter à 4 me en france deux familles
françaises ces chiffres et concepteurs
s'est passé pas si mal que cela ni moins
oui on m'a dit moi ça pourrait être plus
personne n'en sait rien en réalité de
façon précise on verra mais par contre
que le principe que quand une entreprise
gagne de l'argent elle le fait grâce aux
gens qui investissent du capital dans
cette entreprise mais aussi grâce à ses
salariés et que donc on doit partager
que le capital doit être rémunéré mais
que le travail qui a permis les
bénéfices le soit aussi
ça c'est quelque chose qui serait une
vraie voie d'avenir pour la france quand
ça va mal on demande à tout le monde se
serrer la ceinture et quand ça va bien
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il est que le
capital qui touche à l'eba lassus le
gouvernement a parfaitement raison ici
c'est ici ça fâche les patrons et que
satisfait ça nous satisfasse pas les
socialistes mais c'est leur rôle c'est
leur boulot c'est leur job c'est même
leur caricature
ça n'est pas grave ça ça serait quelque
chose qu'on pourrait mettre en place de
façon beaucoup plus pérenne pour que les
gens quand ils font des efforts il en
tire les bénéfices eux aussi allés
mercredi encore nouveau débat relancé
par les socialistes cette fois c'est un
rapport qui préconise une légalisation
contrôlée du cannabis
le groupe de travail était présidée par
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur daniel
vaillant
vous vous êtes là encore prononcé pour
cette proposition en revanche des
députés socialistes sont dits hostiles
dossier donc il a encore dépasse les
clivages traditionnels
matile de terriers ce geste devrait-il
être autorisé où ils répondent cette
dizaine de socialiste mené par l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur daniel vaillant
le fervent défenseur de la légalisation
du cannabis demande dans ce rapport
qu'elle soit contrôlée
je ne suis pas pour favoriser l'accès à
la consommation cannabique faut bien
comprendre ça sinon on n'a rien compris
mais je suis pour m'y prendre autrement
que la prohibition la répression qui ne
fonctionne pas pour le maire du xviiie
arrondissement
face à l'augmentation du trafic de
stupéfiants la dépénalisation ne suffit
pas il faut aller plus loin
organiser la filière du haschich pour
mettre à mal les trafiquants cinquante
trois mille hectares de cultures des
ventes sur licence la création de
cannabis trop ou encore la
reconnaissance de
son usage thérapeutique des propositions
qui ont provoqué cet après-midi la
colère à droite eric raoult et lance
alors une pétition contre la
dépénalisation des drogues douces est
pas une logique économie c'est pas une
réalité urbaine c'est simplement qu'on
commence comme ça et qu'on termine à la
fin par des drogues plus dures
une position ferme partagé aussi par une
partie de la gauche
je suis fermement opposé à la
légalisation du cannabis parce que je
pense que c'est contraire à nos valeurs
sacrées de la dépendance et ça ne règle
pas le problème de fond
d'autres plus prudents hésitent voire
semble gêner ça fait partie des pistes
qu'il a ouverts elles sont mises en
débat on en a discuté au sein du groupe
socialiste est assez partagé je dois
dire sur les solutions sur les voies
empruntées mais qui ne l'est pas sur le
constat d'un échec un tabou qui avait
déjà été soigneusement évité lors de la
dernière présidentielle
car à l'époque 70% des français étaient
hostiles à une possible ouverture de la
législation pourtant chaque année 90
mille personnes sont interpellées pour
usage de cannabis soit huit fois plus
qu'il ya 20 ans même question tout à
l'heure vous êtes prononcé pour pourquoi
pas maintenant
en 2002 je disais déjà la même chose
donc c'est apparemment la dernière nuit
même allemand dernière campagne
présidentielle parce que je pense que on
fausse le débat depuis des années on
nous dit que c'est un an vient de
l'entendre encore d'air que c'est un
débat de santé publique
si vous le placez sur le domaine de la
santé publique il ya trois questions est
ce que ces biens se droguer non est ce
que c'est bon pour la personne non
est-ce qu interdire le cannabis empêche
les gens d'en consommer non non plus
donc c'est pas et là dessus tout le
monde on peut être d'accord il ya même
pas de débat
donc c'est pas un problème de santé
publique c'est devenu un problème de
sécurité publique et je veux dire par là
la chose suivante puisque la prohibition
pas plus qu'à l'époque la prohibition de
l'alcool aux états unis d'empêcher les
gens de voir ça n'a permis qu'à elle
capable de monter les mafias puisque la
prohibition n'empêche pas
les gens de consommer mais qu'elle
permet la constitution de mafia 2 mafia
dans des quartiers que ce truc qui
structurent la vie que la vie sociale de
ces quartiers de massia au niveau
bancaire entre guillemets vous avez une
puissance financière colossale des gros
trafiquants dhr pas ce qu'on cherche en
hollande les vrais patrons et des mafias
au niveau des états on sait ce qu'il en
est par exemple dans des états
d'amérique du sud ou en afghanistan ou
la gare la guerre qui est menée entre
guillemets contre nous là bas est
financé par notre consommation de
cannabis chez nous chez nous à lorsque
vous passez raisonnement à toutes les
drogues ce que je sais que je veux
expliquer c'est la chose suivante je
préférerais que nous ayons une politique
européenne plutôt que de voir
aujourd'hui les fast and go qui vont
chercher en hollande et en espagne et
que effectivement signé non pas une
dépénalisation ça n'a pas de sens
remplacer une peine de prison par une
contravention
une légalisation sous contrôle je
préférerais avoir des consommateurs qui
sont en face de travailleurs sociaux
qu'en face de dealers en face de gens
qui sont là pour les faire sortir de
leur consommation et pas de quelqu'un
qui a intérêt à ce qu'ils consomment
toujours plus je préférerais en
l'occurrence que nous ayons devrait par
exemple politique de prévention à
l'école pour expliquer les dangers pour
montrer par exemple à travers un
simulateur de vol la différence quand
vous êtes un pilote et que vous avez
fumé ou vous n'avez pas fumer du
cannabis
vous posez pas sur la piste pour que les
gens comprennent ça un problème est
européen un problème d'éducation
je voudrais aussi qu'on regarde les
choses en face c'est pas le rapport de
monsieur vaillant tout estimable qui
soit il ya un rapport qui a été fait aux
états unis par des spécialistes
internationaux de la drogue et de la
lutte contre la drogue auxquelles
participent et d'ancien chef d'état
c'est pas des guignols c'est pas des
babas cool c'est pas des types qui ont
envie que tout le monde se droguent et
qu'ils disent mais vous l'avez dit à la
fin du reportage on a multiplié par 8 la
consommation alors que c'est interdit
qu'est ce que vous allez faire il n'y a
pas une ville de france où si vous êtes
consommateur quand vous arrivez en moins
d'une demi heure vous savez où vous
procurer et on nous dit que c'est
efficace
moi je préfère un système qui est
efficace qui évite de structuré des
mafias et qui permet d'avoir une vraie
politique de prévention pour dire que ce
n'est pas bien pour dire que ça n'est
pas bon pour la santé des enfants
mais aujourd'hui la prohibition c'est un
cache sexe c'est une hypocrisie
c'est quelque chose qui fait semblant
l'occurrence de lutter contre cependant
que ça se répand ça a été multiplié par
x 8 ans 20 ans
qu'est-ce qui a multiplié qu'est-ce qui
a d'autres dans la société qui a
multiplié par 8 depuis 20 ans messieurs
christophe lagarde
hervé morin se dit viscéralement hostile
à la dépénalisation et les rd maurer et
le président du nouveau centre dont vous
faites partie des quelque part il vous
dit que vous êtes profondément
irresponsable vous avez remarqué que
chez les centristes on n'était pas dans
une armée doigt sur la couture du
pantalon
hervé morin a le droit d'avoir son
opinion je suis pas sûr que comme député
leur île et une bonne conscience d'une
bonne conscience et connaissance du
sujet je pense qu'il a une réaction
affective
ça veut dire qu'il a besoin de se
renseigner qu'on aura l'occasion de
débattre c'est embêtant quand même au
sein d'un même parti d'avoir des
positions aussi divergentes ouvertement
monsieur vaillant et monsieur valls
avait des positions divergent plus
croyez qu'un parti politique c'est fait
pour tout le monde soit toujours
d'accord sur tout c'est aussi fait pour
ouvrir des débats il ya des sujets de
société vous avez cités celui là mais il
y en a bien d'autres
quand on discutait des lois sur la
bioéthique on est essentielle tous pensé
la même chose
un mouvement politique en général il
regroupe sur une politique européenne et
une politique internationale du parti
radical ne ressent si vous êtes très
proche de jean louis borloo
mais excusez moi je ne suis pas radical
est ce que j'ai le droit de continuer à
être ce que je suis depuis 20 ans comme
militants centristes engagé et si sur ce
point j'ai un désaccord avec hervé morin
a dressé autour d'une table pour
discuter non simplement qui connaît pas
le sujet et la réalité c'est que sur
d'autres sujets on a de nombreux points
d'accord et qu'il apporte des idées dans
le parti avec lesquels je suis parfois
d'accord pas d'accord et vice et versa
et si un parti c'est un homme un chef
qui décide de tout et tout le monde doit
être d'accord
alors ça ressemble aux parties communes
c'est pas mon style alors ça chauffe
aussi chez les verts dernier débat entre
les candidats à la primaire d'europe
écologie les verts
c'était mercredi soir à lille les
échanges sont de plus en plus vifs entre
dans la dernière ligne droite entre eva
joly elle accélère elle a même décidé
d'attaquer son rival nicolas hulot
écouter cette passe d'armes entre les
deux candidats c'est très différente
dire je vais m'adresser à tous les
électeurs sans distinction ni
discrimination et de dire j'ai envisagé
un ticket présidentiel avec un ancien
ministre de sarkozy
ce qui m'a gêné quand tout ceci c'est
que nicolas a décerné un brevet de
respectabilité écologistes à monsieur
borloo
il fait du greenwashing les écologistes
ont déjà dû avaler beaucoup de
couleuvres mais cette fois c'est une
colle havre et qui essayent de nos
avaler l'écologie de combat eva ce n'est
pas l'écologie des coups bas
je me suis plié à une discipline et j'ai
demandé à ma propre équipe de ne jamais
souscrire à la facilité des mots mais
quand j'écoute pendant cinq minutes et
va me mettre dans ma bouche des propos
que je n'ai pas tenu compte tenu du
respect que je porte au parcours d'eva
joly
c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à garder ma
sérénité
jean christophe lagarde eva joly parle
du centre ou de jean louis borloo comme
l'adversaire vous la voyez comme tel
aussi eva joly oui mais je la vois
surtout pas comme écolo en réalité c'est
une femme de gauche et les c'était très
choquant d'ailleurs ce week-end la
secrétaire qui s'est bien sûr sous
prétexte que nicolas hulot disait moi je
pourrais discuté avec jean louis borloo
qui est quand même le ministre de
l'environnement qui a fait faire une
révolution environnementale à la france
voulait qu'on compare le bilan de madame
voynet verte donc écologistes patentés
et le bilan de jean louis borloo
le coût de ce ticket le bon nom le bon
en allant horloger justement c'est ça
qui est intéressant
le bond en avant que la france a fait
sous la direction dans le domaine
environnemental de jean louis borloo n'a
jamais été fait est quasiment par aucun
pays et au moment où elodie bas c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui sur les valeurs
environnementales est compatible avec
nous qu'est-ce qui lui répondit pas
seulement par madame joly mais part d'un
leader
madame duflot etc jal a jamais ce qui
prouve que ce qui l'intéressé pas
l'environnement c'est la gauche
alors pourquoi se cacher derrière
l'environnement pour être une femme de
gauche
dernière chose que montrer ces images de
guerre des choses très rapide ainsi vous
avez aimé la primaire des écologistes
pensent qu'on va adorer celle des
socialistes parce que tous ces gens là
ne sont en général d'accord sur rien et
prétendre gouverner ensemble et 2
quand je regarde nicolas hulot je le dis
objectivement qu'il n'a pas grand chose
à faire chez ces gens là vous lui dites
vous revenez vers le haut
non ben je lui dis traces ton chemin
fais ce que tu veux mais manifestement
entre quelqu'un qui n'est pas très connu
mais qu'on a vu sur les images monsieur
l'homme qui lui dit vraiment est un
traître vendue au lobby financier au
capital et elle qui lui dit tu es qu une
couleuvre qui essayent de nous bouffer
il veut vraiment être leur candidat il a
vraiment quelque chose à faire là je lui
demande de rejoindre l'équipe bordeaux
je dis simplement j'ai l'impression que
nicolas hulot n'est pas à sa place dans
un mouvement politique qui donne
l'apparence de la défense de
l'environnement et qui est en réalité en
train d'essayer tout simplement des kits
de 2,2 de rétablir un rapport de force
qui lui serait favorable avec le parti
socialiste
il ya beaucoup de gens qui étaient au
parti socialiste à l'intérieur et qui
ont préféré les verts parce qu'ils
trouvaient pas leur place au ps allez va
passer au jeudi avec rama yade qui coupe
le dernier cordon qui la rejette à
l'elysée or ce jeudi donc celle qui fut
la plus populaire des ministres de
nicolas sarkozy 'l'annonce elle quitte
son poste d'ambassadrice de l'unesco
qu'elle devait au président poursuivre
totalement dit-elle jean louis borloo
dans la course pour 2012
rama yada l'ingérable parcours c'est un
sujet de céline bittner est thomas
souliers cette image d'embrassades entre
nicolas sarkozy rama yade fait désormais
partie de l'histoire ancienne
rama yade a décidé de prendre les
devants et de quitter son poste
d'ambassadrice de l'unesco pour
s'engager pleinement dans la campagne de
jean louis borloo
j'ai décidé de reprendre ma liberté
explique-t-elle dans cette interview au
monde.fr est le premier à s'en féliciter
c'est jean louis borloo lui-même ham a
fait un choix de cohérence
et un choix de donneurs enfin c'est
conforme à ce qu'on connaît d'elle
voilà pour avoir vos côtés monsieur
borloo a forcément très important le
président du parti radical le c'est rama
yade est pour lui une pièce maîtresse en
cas de candidature à la présidentielle
l'ancien secrétaire d'état très
populaire depuis ses coups de gueule
contre le colonel kadhafi notamment rama
yade qui était dans le collimateur de
l'elysée depuis plusieurs mois trop
médiatique trop critique envers nicolas
sarkozy
aujourd'hui son départ est jugé
préoccupant par bernard accoyer il y a
une majorité les français ont voulu
cette majorité il y a quatre ans et
celle ci aujourd'hui s'apprête
s'approchait d'une division fois qu'une
majorité se divise elle perd les
élections elle prend le risque majeur
vis-à-vis des élections à venir d'autres
à l'ump préfère minimiser la démission
de rama yade
objectif ne pas trop accorder
d'importance à jean louis borloo dont la
probable candidature à la présidentielle
irrite de plus en plus l'elysée rama
yade c'est une belle prise de guerre
pour jean louis borloo
la meilleure c'est pas une prise de
guerre c'est simplement que rama yade
1 il décide de reprendre sa liberté et
ses courageuse et 2 en 2007 l'ump
rassemble les gens très différents
rama yade aussi puis aujourd'hui comme
je le disais c'est quand même plus la
droite populaire qui donne le ton elle
s'y retrouvent pas elle a quand même le
droit d'être libre comme d'autres elle a
le droit d'avoir le choix
comme les français elle l'a fait et
après tout il n'ya pas beaucoup de gens
qui préfèrent leur liberté au plat de
lentilles et les noms planant fils oui à
sa liberté pour qu'on est tous la
liberté d'avoir le choix
merci d'avoir est avec nous à la semaine
prochaine